Florida Governor Ron DeSantis tried
taking the high road against Donald
Trump's recent attack on him and while I
admired DeSantis I guess in some vague
way for not stooping to Trump's level
DeSantis will lose if this is his
approach it didn't work for any of these
Republicans in 2016 it's not going to
work for Ron DeSantis so let's take a
look at this clip the context here I
will remind you is that Donald Trump
published to truth social truth
essential a picture of Ron DeSantis with
some allegedly high school girls
retrothing a message that argued that
Ron was grooming high school girls
Donald Trump posting that's not Ron is
it he would never do such a thing Ron
DeSantis was asked about this he
attempted to take the high road listen
to this
I spend my time delivering results for
the people of Florida and fighting
against Joe Biden that's how I spend my
time
[Applause]
[Music]
I don't spend my time trying to smear
other Republicans
yeah
uh oh how great Ron really really great
you took the high road you will lose if
this is what you do he doesn't have a
chance in hell of defeating Donald Trump
if that is going to be his approach it's
not what Republican voters want to see
at this point he's going with the I'm
above this sort of approach on this
thing and they tried it in 2016. it did
not work it might have gotten you two
three four five six seven percent but
then Trump Consolidated support and
Consolidated and Consolidated DeSantis
does have the possibility of defeating
Donald Trump in a 2024 primary DeSantis
hasn't even announced that he is running
at this point and he's polling really
well against the former president when
he hasn't even said I am actually a
candidate for this office this is not
about DeSantis can't win but think back
to a couple weeks ago a month ago a
month ago two months ago when I told you
pulling aside
I don't know that DeSantis
constitutionally
personality wise has what it takes to go
up against Trump and Trump's nicknames
and Trump's insults in a national
campaign I don't know whether DeSantis
has it in him the fact that he is
already going with I'm above this stuff
I'm not going around criticizing other
Republicans I don't waste my time on
this sort of thing there is not a chance
in hell that DeSantis wins with that
approach if you disagree with me I want
to hear from you I just don't see it and
part of the reason why is that these
Republican voters many of these
Republican voters they don't want unity
and decorum and the right tone or any of
this stuff they voted for Trump they
voted for the guy who said grab them by
the you know what was drawing stuff with
sharpies and said that woman's not
attractive enough for me to ever have
sexually assaulted her they they don't
want Little Marco and Ted Cruz's wife is
ugly and all this different stuff that's
what they wanted that's what they voted
for and while many of them will tell you
a oh I want to return to Civility and
all these things and some of them
genuinely do want that
the romney-esque ones most of them don't
most of them want that Alpha energy that
they claim comes from Donald Trump
uh and they're not going to go for this
so if this is the santis approach he is
dead in the water on this campaign that
hasn't even started yet disagree with me
let me know agree with me I want to hear
from you as well you know I have a very
acute Newfound appreciation for how busy
being a new parent makes you if you have
a little one at home like me here's
something really easy you can do to
simplify your life our sponsor little
spoon is your One-Stop shop for healthy
easy meal time and snack time for your
baby toddler or big kid delivered right
to your door little spoon delivers fresh
organic baby food which comes in single
ingredient varieties or multi-textured
purees little spoon is meals for
toddlers and big kids they're free of
junk and taste great even the pickiest
eaters love them I've even tried many of
them myself they really are great having
healthy snack time is so so easy with
little spoons organic smoothies which
come in convenient pouches in great
flavors like strawberry banana shake
purple carrot acai I love purple carrots
I'm going to admit that my girlfriend
and I have had a great experience with
our little spoon subscription it just
makes life easier anything to reduce the
chaos is a great thing little spoon is
giving my audience 50 off your first
order go to littlespoon.com and use code
Pacman 50 off all one word the info is
down below